Speaker 1: Let's go to the audience. Why? Because
without the audience, I'm just a guy with a mic
talking to a wall. And let's first go to Trent
from Wisconsin via Dischord David Pakman Dotcom
discord is the place to talk to me. Join the
discussion. Trent from Wisconsin, what's going on?
Speaker 3: Hey there, David. Happy Wednesday to
you. Recently here in my home state of Wisconsin,
Paul Ryan just yesterday came out and boldly
said to the GOP of Wisconsin that, yes,
Biden won the election. It was not
rigged whatsoever. And obviously,
it's been quite some time since Paul Ryan has had
really a strong foothold on the GOP itself. But
he does have a very large presence here in the
state of Wisconsin. So my question to you is,
do you see more Republicans like Paul Ryan type
coming out and really taking a stand against
more local governments like Wisconsin who are
pushing a lot more election lies, including
the most recent bill that passed, costing over
six hundred thousand dollars of taxpayer money
to go towards an election investigation,
Speaker 1: to be totally honest with you. The
reason I think Paul Ryan is just coming out and
directly saying, guys, Trump lost and Biden won
is because he's not looking to get more involved,
because I think if he were looking to get more
involved, he would have to tread a little more
carefully, because at last check, more than half
of the Republican Party still seems to believe
that Donald Trump actually won the election. So
I think that the question people have been
asking is, when is a Republican like Paul Ryan,
who tells the truth about the election,
going to run on the basis of telling the
truth? I think the reason he's telling the
truth is he's not planning to run, because I
don't know that there's really an appetite in
the Republican Party right now for a guy who
is going to tell it like it is. They
want to keep being told what Matt
Gates says and what Green says. But by
and large. So, no, I mean, I think that
the most likely thing is Paul Ryan is free to
say what he wants because he's not particularly
interested in getting back in politics.
Speaker 3: Yeah, definitely, I can agree with
that on just about every point there, I guess the
big thing is, does he really have an influence of
any kind, even from a local politics level?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think in Wisconsin,
he's still a guy that the reasonable
Republicans listen to. The only question is
how many of the Republicans in Wisconsin
are reasonable? And I just don't know enough
about what's going on there to say for sure.
Speaker 3: Right, right. Well, with a guy like
Robin Vos running our state legislature,
I can easily tell you that there isn't
a lot of room for reasoning when it comes to the
Wisconsin GOP. It's really something interesting
and frustrating just because of the fact that
Wisconsin in political history has a lot of
really great history when it comes to both just
left leaning politics. And now we see the extremes
of the right leaning politics ever since Scott
Walker had taken over as governor years ago.
Speaker 1: Peter, listen, I think that the
trigger point for it becoming more reasonable
in the Wisconsin GOP and others would be if the
Magga Trump is nuttery loses in twenty two, I
think they'll reconsider for twenty four.
Speaker 3: Awesome, thank you. All right,
Speaker 1: thank you for the
call very much. Appreciate it.